the first store we have from the daily
mail virginia georgia and north carolina
declare state of emergency over gas
shortages
after colonial pipeline hack as 1 000
fuel stations run dry in southeast
as people panic by they say ralph
northam and brian kemp
governors of virginia and georgia
declared a state of emergency on tuesday
on monday the governor of north carolina
roy cooper took a similar step to deal
with the fuel crisis
now they're going to mention a lot of
stuff most of us already know that the
pipeline was hacked it's ransomware it's
the largest pipeline
in the country i'm not entirely
convinced i think we're being lied to by
the government
you know so we heard from the from a dhs
uh one of the people spoke people from
the dhs
there's no shortage we're seeing the new
york times say there's no long lines
there was another story camera board
challenge was saying there's there's no
long lines everyone calmed down
but here's what i find strange the daily
mail is reporting it's panic buying
why why is it so heavily prominent in
north carolina is it just
something about people in north carolina
where they're more prone to panic and
buying
is it just panic buying i don't know
what do you think i don't know um
why north carolina particularly i will
say um the region of the country where i
live and even coming here tonight every
gas station i
passed had very long lines you don't
live far away from us no
and everybody knows where we live by the
way just you know and i filled up this
morning i got up early
because i saw the news last night and
i've been following this and i thought
you know what i'm just
uh going to get up and first thing i did
was i took my car
uh i took the other car i took our gas
cans and i just filled up everything
just to be safe so was i panic buying
absolutely i was
i'm sure a lot of people are doing the
same but it raises a larger question
about
infrastructure and and just for think a
couple of weeks ago when
the media cycle was easier right it's
amazing how crazy and how fast the media
cycle goes
when when the president introduces
infrastructure bill and everyone began
joking
saying health care is infrastructure and
poetry is infrastructure
and childhood dreams are infrastructure
now this really is infrastructure
like infrastructure is infrastructure
and i think one of the biggest
challenges i have in my industry is that
oil and gas isn't always sexy energy
isn't always safe it's not titillating
it's not
guns it's not abortion half the country
hates it but
but boy oh boy is it really the
lifeblood of our economy and we're
getting a taste of what happens when
when it's tinkered with
this is what what freaks me out you saw
you you remember when greta tunberg was
like we're not talking about 2030 or
2022 we want right now
shut it down you got it look what's
happening when there's just
45 percent of supply in the south on the
east coast in the southeast
is disrupted this is what happens what
do you think would happen if they
actually got their way and shut down
everything yeah exactly and and we have
a larger
energy infrastructure problem because
most of us most of our refining
happens in very strategic areas right
the refining happens in the gulf
because historically we imported most of
our oil it was
cheaper to bring it in by barge so you
wanted it by the water and
the eastern seaboard because it was
coming from from
the middle east the eastern seaboard was
all really expensive real estate so
there was nowhere to go so they went
around florida
and they ended they ended up in the gulf
coast and that's where the refining is
and if you see a map
of the refineries and then a map of the
pipelines
pipelines everywhere but there really is
just one pipeline from the gulf coast
all the way and that's colonial pipeline
and it is a major pipeline should we
have built a second a third or fourth
absolutely should we have refining in
the northeast
we should but you also have to remember
we refine a lot in the south
because just in terms of chemistry
refining takes a lot of heat
it's less of less expensive and more
efficient
to refine something that is already warm
than to do it in a cold environment so
of course we were fine in this so this
is like the the barges bring the raw
patro the crude petroleum
yes and his refineries turn it into
other stuff like like gas what
else do they make the the crew that
comes out of the ground is refined into
literally hundreds of different products
so the reason why my organization why i
why we fight sometimes a lot of these
renewable fuel standards and cafe
standards
is not because we don't believe in in
protecting the environment but because
if you are california for example has
over 50 different blends
of oil right for four different for
different seasons for different vehicles
if you're a refinery and you have to
produce 50 products think of a bartender
it's a lot easier just to be porn beers
but if you have to make 50 different
cocktails
well every time you've got a stop you've
got to switch well every time you do
that it drives up the price a little bit
a little bit a little bit
this one pipeline is bringing not just
one type of fuel
but multiple types of fuels and every
state has their own special blend
because a bunch of idiot politicians who
know nothing about energy
pass a law they're like we want the
blend to look like this and and
and everyone claps and that's so so this
pipeline isn't just like
one big tube no it's like a bunch of
small tubes
in a big tube exactly a series of tubes
and they have said some of the smaller
ones and i forget what there is a phrase
for it and
i don't know if they're called the
ancillary ones the the secondary ones
but there is a phrase form a lot of
those
the i forget i wish i remember the names
a lot of them are starting to come
online
but the big jammies they're gonna be
offline for a little while and that's
really really frightening so i'm hearing
uh people are tweeting out that we're
importing
gas now from europe we're trying to
bring in some energy is that true
well you know this is where energy gets
a little bit ugly because we've always
imported quote unquote because we refine
so for example some of the big energy
companies
companies really that don't like me
necessarily because they don't
they will say you shouldn't ban uh
imports from the middle east because we
refined those
those oil and this is bad for our
company and my response is
i'm not here for your company i'm here
what is good for america and if
importing oil from the middle east is
good for your company what the heck do i
care
right so but if you're a refiner do you
want to buy saudi oil at nine dollars a
barrel or do you want to buy permian
basin oil
at 45 a barrel i'll buy the saudi oil
well
that's not good for america they would
say well but it's good because then we
sell it cheaper into the american grid
at the expense of american energy
interests right so we do always
import quote unquote because we refine
it but not on the pacific coast
alaska think how crazy this is alaska
sends its oil
at this point now to china to be refined
to come back to america because we can't
we can't build a refinery in the
northwest they do that with a lot of
products
we can't build refineries in the pacific
northwest the very green groups that say
we need to get our fossil fuels
are making us go 9000 miles across the
pacific to refine in china
and by the way the chinese refineries
are environmental standards you would
not believe right
oh amazing oh gosh yes and then we barge
it back to america but no
no you mean like awful oh my god you
sounded like you're about to say they're
so great you would not believe how
amazing all the nine-year-old girls that
work in those refineries
they get paid at least a dollar a day
wow right exactly
so so china then benefits from the fact
that the green groups that don't allow
us
to build a refinery in america because
it's bad for the environment
same with the keystone pipeline right we
the very first conversation i was here
keystone had just shut it down right is
that oil not going to houston of course
it's going to houston but it's going by
train or by truck
i'm sorry man this is just infuriating
because you know what i
referred to this today as a political
drive-by yeah you look at you look at
msnbc and cnn you have all of all of
those viewers and voters
stopped watching yeah now that trump
isn't president anymore
they based their vote off of hating
somebody not for
something yeah and the first thing we
get a lot of people were in favor of joe
biden shutting down keystone
now keystone's shut down a lot of union
guys lost their jobs
and now we're we're dealing with this
crisis with this pipeline
well they're coming out and saying
there's no shortage there's no shortage
i don't i don't i i'm sorry if i don't
believe them no i mean there's a
shortage at the gas stations it's a fact
yes and for whatever reason maybe it's
panic or otherwise
they're not able to get the the fuel
back up there so even if it is panic
what do you think happens panic should
be should be baked into the
the the plan we should know if there is
a disruption panic happens
well thanks to joe biden keystone's not
going to be available it makes me think
of don't buy them
we don't need you don't need a mask
remember that right when it came out
fauci
was like i thought she said that you
don't need them after two weeks they
didn't want to run on the masks
if they said there's an oil shortage
there would be a run on the oil they
don't want to run on the oil
and so and so it's good it's a good
point fauci came out
and later and admitted we were concerned
that medical professionals wouldn't get
it so we said that
and that's what i see now in the new
york times said there's no long lines
i think what happens is these people in
media no longer
is their job to inform the population so
they can make decisions for themselves
they've become the the self-appointed
nannies of the state
where the new york times is like just
tell them nothing's happening so they
stay home
but then people who pay attention like i
mean you had the biggest advantage
you're the energy guy daniel so when
this happened you probably got word
before anybody else
and you're like better go to the gas
station people are like what are you
doing don't mind me i'm just filling up
all these tanks
i did tell my family very early on that
they want to go and
i should have made it more of a public
announcement but yeah
like a lot of this is foreign but a lot
of this
is foreseeable um and and there is a
supply issue right
keystone is a supply issue as you reduce
the supply of any good
and the demand does not diminish while
the price is going to escalate so
if you could say well i don't like
keystone it's bad for the environment
i'm saying that when you take it away
you are causing a supply concern
it's still coming like i said it's
coming by rail or it's coming by by car
uh by truck but that's expensive so we
are the goal takes fuel to do that it
does of course it does yeah
the goal of the one of the jobs of the
president and this is where i do lay
this at the feet of president biden did
he cause the cyber
i lay this at the feet of president
biden because the president
we all know is extremely powerful and
can send signals that can tank the stock
market yeah or can make industries
go through the roof trump would tweet
and people would become millionaires or
lose a million dollars and that is the
power and and and for
for good or ill that is the power of the
president joe biden has been sending
signals since the campaign during
transition and now as president
and he does not want to accept the
consequence of the signals so he
signaled that he has no problem with any
illegal immigrant coming across the
border what do we have now four and five
times the record
they're wearing those shirts biden
please let us know he sent a signal
right and people listened and they
responded he sent a signal
that israel's not necessarily our friend
i know that's the next topic he gave
money back
to the palestinians right he re-sent re
restarted that funding
he sent a signal that israel is not our
strategic partner what's happening right
now in israel he sent a signal on day
one that energy infrastructure
is not important he signed that keystone
thing he sent a signal
and people are responding i tweeted you
know i guess build back better means
crumbling infrastructure
crisis of the middle east mass exodus
from the workforce unemployment
and i get these lefties being like dude
it's trump's fault or whatever and i'm
like oh it's a magical coincidence
that biden's policy ending executive
orders from donald trump the remain in
mexico
uh the the migrant protection protocols
remain in mexico policy
or shutting down keystone pipeline or
the 300
unemployment stimulus those policies
which he's enacted in the past several
months
have no impact on those those crises
that are happening right now
it's it's absurd to think that it's a
coincidence and we had what was it david
frum i think was it from
yeah who was like oh but everyone was
cheering for trump's the in the middle
east and it's like
oh and then and then and then three
months in with joe biden
it's trump's fault now of course amazing
it's amazing it's a magical coincidence
it was it's it's as if they believe
donald trump was holding the country
together with a duct tape
and then as soon as he left now all the
problems are emerging sorry
2019 jim cramer cnn was it cnbc i think
best numbers of our lives the economy
was a booming don't get me wrong
he was spending a lot of money and that
bill always comes due but it's very
different compared to what we saw with
republicans
and democrats last year just cranking up
the stimulus now we've got to pay for it
yeah now now we have
this oil pipeline it's uh
crumbling infrastructure is an
understatement when we have a real
problem in america politically because
we live in an instagram social media
twitter world
it's great for fast communication
communication and agility
but it's bad because candidates now
target their entire campaign around that
buildback better is a wonderful
alliterative bumper sticker
it is not policy right and all of his
proclamations and my dad told me joey
and he looked me in the eye and all
those little stories acute on the
campaign trail but now you actually have
to govern
and i don't think kind of like president
obama i don't think president biden
really wants to govern i think
i agree i think he likes the uh campaign
i don't think
confronting a guy who was banging a
straight razor on a curb put in a rain
barrel to get it all rusty
i don't think that's the experience
someone needs to actually run the
country but it was a great story i guess
you know people had a laugh about it uh
what what did he call
what do you call that one that corn pop
no he called corn pop a name
do you remember what the name dude no no
he's the variable he's
esther he called it esther williams yeah
which i'm i'm
i'm happy to say i'm too young i'm too
young to know what esther williams
who esther williams is or why that was
important i think i think joe biden
just wanted to be president and then i'm
sure that
you know he he stands he's probably
sitting in a wheelchair looking in the
mirror with a smile on his face
and people are running around frantic
behind him there's like papers flying
and the phone's ringing off the hook and
like
his assistant's hair's all frazzled and
they're like i don't know what to do
about israel and but it's like
president come on man you know what i
bet he didn't even want to be president
because he didn't run in 2016.
made me think like he's he doesn't want
it he doesn't care he would have run a
hundred percent the vp comes out they go
right into it
seamless he didn't want it in the dnc he
hated trump yeah they
they wrapped him up he was like i have a
right he felt like a
a force of god like this is my purpose
here i must do this he didn't want it
he wasn't capable he just went along he
got pushed along now say
donald trump really wanted yes and he
still does and he still does
um not like he was a perfect like
there's a lot of people who think he's
you know they call him the god emperor
most of them joking but some people are
serious i think it would
we would have been better off i
certainly think so but i guess the
the the interests of the
military-industrial complex types and
the international monetary fund types
they weren't too happy with donald trump
being like america america
they're like no no no we we we make
money off of you know exporting the
reserve currency and
putting guns in a bunch of different
countries thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus
episodes thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time
you